Esta es una ciudad en niveles hecha por Conflictnerd,
y la idea básica es que se tiene rutas circulares concéntricas.
Así que la ciudad es un gran círculo con círculos concéntricos más pequeños.
La cuestión es que se ponen todos los servicios en el centro,
y la gente vive de hecho en el anillo exterior,
porque allí hay menos tráfico, menos ruido, menos contaminación;
y ese es un lugar deseable para vivir.
Pero, aún así, los servicios están muy cerca;
están en el centro.
Y este es el espíritu del juego,
el jugador tiene que entender cuáles son los deseos y las necesidades
de las minorías rurales que viven en las ciudades.
Así que se necesita saber dónde se debería poner cada cosa.
No es suficiente tener un hospital, necesita ser accesible,
los ciudadanos necesitan llegar a él.
Y esta es una forma de hacerlo.
Así que esto es algo que quizá podamos ver algún día.
Ahora, siendo más futuristas,
Astergea, de Yuttho.
Yuttho hace videos en Youtube y prueba el juego.
Lo que él hizo aquí fue, de hecho, una serie de 12 puntos
para crear esta ciudad.
Así que lo que hace es crear en el juego
y lo graba
mientras que explica lo que hace y por qué.
Y, como parte de esta serie,
él hizo una entrevista con un verdadero urbanista
llamado Jeff Speck.
Speck es un experto en el concepto de transitabilidad.
La idea básica es que si se desea que los ciudadanos caminen,
lo cual es beneficioso,
se necesitaría considerar el caminar como un medio razonable de transporte.
Esa debería ser una buena forma de conectar lugares.
Así que Yuttho explicó este concepto,
hizo que Speck también lo explicara
y luego lo aplicó a la ciudad que estaba construyendo.
Así que lo que estamos viendo es la visión del futuro de Yuttho:
una gran cantidad de transporte público, caminos y plazas
conectando grandes edificios.
Quizá así pueda lucir el futuro.
Y el sistema del juego funciona muy bien para esto;
estamos viendo usos para el mundo real con este juego.
Sabemos que algunos urbanistas están usándolo como una herramienta;
ya que, aunque la simulación no es completamente realista,
lo es lo suficiente, tanto que si funciona en el juego,
es muy probable que también funcione en el mundo real;
de modo que se pueden probar cosas,
como ver si esta intersección podría encajar en esta situación.
Si construimos una nueva carretera, ¿ayudaría?
Esto es lo que podemos hacer con este juego.
Hubo un concurso muy interesante organizado
por la ciudad finlandesa de Hämeenlinna.
Resulta que tenían una nueva área
que deseaban desarrollar en la ciudad.
Así que hicieron un mapa real de la ciudad,
dejaron vacía el área que querían desarrollar
y compartieron ese mapa
con el fin de que cualquiera lo descargara,
jugara, construyera el área
y enviara sus creaciones al consejo municipal.
Aún no se ha construido nada,
pero pueda que usen uno de estos planos
hechos con el juego
para construir una ciudad real.
Y de estos videos que les he mostrado,
estas son las personas que están ideando nuevos tipos de soluciones.
Sabemos que las ciudades crecen,
lo hacen a medida que avanzamos,
y se prevé que el porcentaje de la población urbana aumente.
Así que necesitamos soluciones y estas personas, los jugadores,
están probando diferentes tipos de soluciones.
Ellos pueden tener algo realmente importante.
Así que aquí vemos ciudades de ensueño que pueden ser reales algún día.
Así que puede ser que este no sea solo un juego,
puede ser una forma para decidir nuestro futuro.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)